hello and welcome to the new order of
your source for everything anime and
manga and today i would like to discuss
a particularly memorable event in the
life of hunter hunter being the conflict
between krapika
and uvoguine as well as how masterfully
it embodies the entire concept of
revenge
so this is one of my personal favorite
fights within series and in my opinion
it's a very classic example of togashi
just going and elevating the shonen
genre because combat can be a really
basic and sometimes even boring exercise
even in some of the greater titles but
what togashi tends to do quite
brilliantly
with key battles in hunter hunter is
make it so the actual
fighting is completely secondary to an
idea or a character moment being
explored and those ideas and moments
will come shortly after this break which
is designed to broaden you into
subscribing to the new world review
which will result in regular hunt onto
content being uploaded straight
into your youtube feed and also because
i'm a bit of a self-shill i also need to
make you aware that i have a new channel
called team pokemon which is all about
experiencing the wonderful world of
pokemon
all through the eyes of a 30 year old
passive aggressive retail worker so even
if you're not a pokemon fan the channel
is quite fun so i hope to see you over
there as well but back to things you're
actually you know
interested in this particular fight
tells you everything you need to know
about krapika and his path going forward
in the story
which is all centered on the concept of
revenge which is usually a very fun idea
to explore given how easy it is to get
on board with it as a reader or watcher
there's an innate sense of satisfaction
one can gain from following a character
seeking and successfully enacting
revenge think stuff like
kill bill and just how wildly
entertaining it is which is bizarre
because there isn't that much to it when
you think about it just a woman slicing
people up
all over the globe that's effectively it
but it works well enough thanks to that
raw
driving force of revenge and that is
very much the crutch of the crop
character in hunt hunter in the very
beginning of the series he had a
powerful mission statement which
consisted of him saying
i do not fear death what i fear is that
my rage will one day fade away
so revenge and i guess arguably some
sort of perceived justice is like
oxygen to krapika at this stage he can't
really live without it
it's twisted it is unhealthy and it is
ultimately unsatisfactory and empty
as revenge often is and that is what
this fight against of again goes to
great
lengths to portray but i first want to
dispel any grand ideas that krapika went
into his phantom troop crusade with a
justifiable cause so obviously that
group having murdered his entire clan in
an act of genocide is quite possibly one
of the most enraging thoughts one could
have and it's very natural to be on the
side of krapika here wanting to hunt
these guys down and deliver retribution
and an
argument can be made that the phantom
troop are simply too dangerous to allow
to exist in this world and if that was
krapika's main driving force then this
would be a completely different matter
as that would be an almost noble cause
actually
using your pain to secure the betterment
of the world at large our blonde boy
korapika
is nowhere near that generous though at
the time of york new city yes retrieving
the scarlet eyes was important to him
but of equal importance was making sure
that the phantom troop were not only
removed from this world but they suffer
and ideally feel a sense of remorse just
prior to them being removed
mercilessly from existence and this is
shown very clearly in his brief
flashback with izunavi when krabika says
that there are people at large who need
to be chained to hell
and that is a very powerful and slightly
terrifying statement to make because all
of a sudden it seems like the recovery
of the scarlet eyes and laying his clan
to rest
is actually a secondary task but the
first being to inflict as
much i suppose damnation on the phantom
troop as possible
and once again this is all epitomized
within the conflict with overgain
because karapika doesn't seem to go into
this fight with the simple goal of
defeating him he wants to
impact duvagine and destroy him mentally
as well as physically
he wanted uvagine to suffer as much as
he and his clans folk had essentially
and you can see this in action as he
repeatedly gloats in front of overgain
saying stuff like
is that the best punch you've got or
going so far as to reveal his eyes and
explain his ridiculously overpowered nun
abilities or even more so pushing
uvagine to use his full power
if graphica was going into battle with
the objective of just reading of again
from the world and enacting some sort of
justice
then he would just kill overkin as
quickly as possible rather than drag out
this interaction
and yes the argument can be made that
krapika was only pushing over gin to
that 100 point in order to test out his
own limits and make sure that his nun
abilities could handle the rest of the
troop but then again that's only true in
the case of chain jail and even then it
was meant to be a purely physical test
because chain jail enforces the state of
zetsu so aura and nen
are completely irrelevant by that point
so you do need to ask yourself
why did krapika push overgain into a
state of maximum or
output with lions like stop wasting my
time use your full power
and well in my personal reading of it it
was to inflict a maximum sense of
despair upon overkeen it was to make him
feel powerless and completely outclassed
just as the members of the kurt klan had
felt when uvegan was slaughtering them
for personal profit
in essence it wasn't a sneaky cheap
victory which karapika was perfectly
capable of achieving he made sure to
allow uvagine to max himself out before
promptly smacking him back down with the
giant metaphorical hammer of court of
justice or at least that was the general
idea but did this
actually work graphica went into this
fight with what i would say was close to
a 100 percent chance of victory hoover
games fate was actually sealed the very
moment he encountered karapika a second
time
with that said i'm gonna throw in
another little twist thing here
because even with all of that in mind in
my opinion
this entire conflict was an overwhelming
defeat for karapika and a lot of this
has to do because of the criteria that
krapika himself had set i remind you of
that quote again
there are people in this world who need
to be chained to hell krapika wanted
overkin to suffer perhaps even repent
well you know what we don't even have to
go that far
he wanted uvagine to show some sort of
emotional response
to being the target of revenge he wanted
to begin to know that his prior actions
were going to cause his death
and elicit some sort of anger fear
bargaining
whatever but uvagine gave karapika
nothing but then there's also the other
side of this coin as well
we do need to assess what uvekin's goal
in this conflict was and it's not
entirely simple because it does change
throughout the battle interestingly
enough at first uvaguin is also out for
revenge he breaks out of his
imprisonment and swears to kill karapika
however just before the fight actually
begins in earnest this goal changes
because the two chat briefly and
karapika makes his own goal of revenge
clear and as such uvagine responds by
saying the following
you know what gives me the most pleasure
taking avengers like you
and smacking them down which i should
say is the viz manga translation of the
events
the official anime subtitles make the
statement even more interesting because
in that incarnation luvign says that
what he loves most in this world
is denying those who come in search of
revenge but that there is our setup
krapika wants over again to suffer for
his actions and uvagine wants to deny
krapika that satisfaction so with that
in mind how does this battle play out
well not well for grapica not very well
at all and this ranges from very simple
things like krapika trying to provoke
kuvagine into a state of rage which
simply doesn't work i mean i briefly
mentioned before that he tried to gloat
by asking overgain if that was the
strongest punch he had which did twig or
again briefly but he pretty immediately
recovered and even used the challenge to
generate a sense of excitement within
himself
for a lot of this fight he was having
the time of his life and in fact even in
some of ubergen's final moments when
kropika revealed his scarlet eyes
instead of feeling any sense of you know
oh [ __ ] luv again just remembered how
strong the curta clown was
and got even more excited despite the
fact that he was helplessly trapped
within chain jail already there was no
fear whatsoever in this man and
everything krapika was doing to him
only had the opposite effect of what was
intended and meanwhile i can't really
say that krapika was doing too well
mentally himself and actually you can
tell quite a bit about his temperament
from a prior conversation that occurred
with uvagine when he was initially
captured the spider was completely
calmed whilst krapika immediately
lost his cool and lashed out against the
defensive subagain from there to now
nothing had really changed so as much as
krapika at all times held both the
physical and tactical advantages
uvagine always held the emotional upper
hand this man
is an emotional rock he could not be
moved by anything that krapika could
throw against him meanwhile kropica's
rage only grew and grew especially when
it became clear to overgain that there
would be no escape and he just calmly
said
kill me and then there was the final
moment where croppiky used judgement
chain on overgain
in an attempt to extract information
about the other troop members and
instead of trying to salvage or even
prolong his life luvagine just said
get lost fool and embraced death denying
karapika
almost everything that he came into this
fight seeking uvagin died satisfied that
he had denied a sense of vengeance to
krapika
whatever victory there was was entirely
empty all karapica gained from it was a
bulky corpse to bury
otherwise though this was like i said
completely empty and not
only that you could even make an
argument that at the end of all of this
uvagine was the more noble combatant in
this battle and that's because as much
as he is
obviously a mass murderer in the end he
prioritized the well-beings of his
comrades over his own life for someone
who willingly took part in a genocide he
showed this bizarre sense of nobility
that all of the core troop members have
and this is a huge part of the reason
why uvagan is so highly regarded amongst
the spiders it's not just because of his
insane strength it's because of his
loyalty and camaraderie it's
absolutely twisted beyond all hell but
that's just the reality of the phantom
troop
and from their perspective uvagine would
have died as a hero perhaps even a
martyr but then when we look back at
krapika
and well what was he actually was he
some sort of noble avenger not really
because there isn't anybody who would
gain satisfaction from uvagine's death
not even krapika himself
because he failed to extract any of his
own personal desires from it the large
majority of which were rooted in
absolute darkness anyway
and that is a very clear window into
krapika's future in hunter hunter so
long as he pursues the path of revenge
every encounter is going to end in this
manner and i think that he very much
realized that by the end of york new
city and after pakunota's incidental
death to this day krapaka has not
actually killed anybody
in his quest to reclaim the scarlet eyes
although it is implied that he has
committed plenty of other
horrid actions but he has not taken a
life directly for his vendetta he has of
course killed people out of acts of
self-defense but that's a different
matter and i think that's because he
recognizes that overkin's death brought
him a grand
total of nothing and here is where i
should probably lay out some differences
in the 1999 anime incarnation
because it is quite fascinating the
concept i've gone through here is
essentially the same
except they make the idea a lot clearer
some may even say they smack you over
the head with it but with a couple of
very major differences the most profound
is that in the izunavi flashback
they give him the following piece of
dialogue even if you are successful
you'll have nothing to gain from it
you'll only be left with emptiness and
blood on your hands you don't have the
strength to carry that burden this
is your last chance let it go forget
revenge
and this is kind of well because neither
the manga nor the 2011 anime incarnation
which follows the monk more closely
has izunavi come anywhere close to
making a statement like this
and in fact he's actually fully
supportive of krapika's revenge quest
although he does attempt to restrain him
from making actions that are a bit too
hasty and self-destructive but at no
point does he deliver anything close to
this kind of noble dialogue to try and
convince cropica not to embark on his
journey and so i think this dialogue
from the 1999 version is just fleshing
out the idea for the audience a lot more
i don't think it's necessary because all
of the pieces are there to embody that
meaning though and they do go on to
highlight the idea further
because another very interesting change
is made immediately after krapika kills
overgain which is that he hunches over
and covers his face with his hand like
he's just gone into a state of shock as
a result of the act of killing
once again this is absolutely not
present in the manga or the 2011 anime
where krapika just moves on with his
life afterwards as a bit of an empty
shell so it is interesting that the 1999
version chose to more fully depict a
negative effect of his actions
and i'm certain that this is what
krapika is feeling on the inside this
kind of struggle between rage incarnate
and the sheer disgust and horror that he
probably feels regarding himself the
1999 version just chose to more
physically express it and as for one
final difference before the battle
actually starts
we see kropika saying a prayer to the
kurt clan with lines like i shall sing
eternal praise to the people of goethe
which establishes his goal as more noble
than i think it is in reality
and in general i think the 1999 anime
version attempts to cast krapika
as much more redeemable than he is in
the other two versions
more like a lost soul in a torrent of
darkness rather than a creature
conjuring said torrent of darkness which
is what i would say the manga and the
2011 versions of him are but look no
matter what version we look at this
conflict remains supremely impressive i
for one love that togashi can very
consistently structure fights with a
physical victor who ends up being the
overall loser
that's a point i've explored with gom vs
pito and just as with that one i'm sure
there are going to be many many people
out there who disagree with the idea
that uvagine won this encounter but in
the end he died entirely proud of his
life
as well as his final actions in denying
croppika any sense of satisfaction
from actually killing him meanwhile
karopika lived on having not only failed
in what he wanted to achieve from
overgain but also having lost part of
himself and then just continuing to
trudge forward on his incredibly
self-destructive path uvagine won the
battle of emotion and the struggle of
ideals meanwhile all karapika 1
was a corpse not the greatest of
outcomes but a beautiful portrayal of
revenge and action
as well as one of my favorite fight
scenes in all of media from togashi but
what do you guys think please do leave
your thoughts in the comments below or
even join my discord server and if
you're game for some more hunt
hunt content then please do go and check
out some of my other videos or even
subscribe to the channel the regular
hunt on to glory delivered straight into
your youtube feed but for now this has
been the new world review and i'll see
you next time